[Musique]
j'étais là j'avais jamais vu ça des fois
il vaut mieux pas se replonger dans les
souvenirs
là par exemple je viens de re visionner
quelques photos quelques photos d'aix et
ça c'est les choses mieux vaut éviter
parce que chez fatwa mais moi j'étais
les champions pompe verlag moi je me
suis fait larguer un paquet de fois
d'ailleurs maintenant c'est moi qui les
relient souvenirs j'ai quelques
souvenirs à l'époque où je me suis fait
larguer et franchement tu es dans le mal
à l'époque j'aurais nez comme donne des
conseils et c'est ce que je vais faire
sans prétention aucune mais arrive un
moment avec la joue forcément un peu
plus d'expérience donc là je joue un peu
au grand frère et fils et des conseils
pour savoir deux choses la première
bombe a tu passe à autre chose et effet
l'art y est c'est terminé
next tu passe à la suivante ou alors
deuxième chose c'est un sentimental est
un peu plus comme moi alors à ce moment
là j'ai fait quelques tuyaux pour
essayer de récupérer ton ex
il ya un moment dans la vie où tu es pas
forcément armé moi avec ma belle tête de
mickey à l'époque je n'étais pas bien
bien armés mais c'est pas grave ça
n'empêchait pas de vouloir conquérir
mon ex quoi à mon ex c'est tout comme
alors je vais te filer les tuyaux pour
savoir comment reconquérir ton ex quand
vous êtes séparés et que tu veut filer
le parfait amour
donc aujourd'hui on va voir comment
reconquérir son ex
moore bon alors la première ça s'excite
est arrivé là je pense que tu es dans le
mall en règle générale les personnes qui
vont bien voir cette vidéo sont des
personnes qui se sont fait larguer donc
si tu es là c'est qu'il doit être un peu
triste la mine blafarde tu dois faire
chier tous tes potes parler que de ton
ex en boucle t'inquiète pas maman poule
et moi je suis là je te comprends ils
devaient défiler quelques clés qui vont
aider parce que je regarde un peu sur le
net surtout n'importe quoi et maquis de
file des techniques secrètes qui
permettrait de retrouver une ex comme ça
avec avec des
des techniques et des astuces fait de
bric et de broc non il ya une seule
chose qui marche c'est déjà la sincérité
faire un point sur toi et tu verras
c'est ce qu'ils payent les mieux si la
rupture a eu lieu il ya déjà un bon
moment
laisse tomber le réchauffé ça ne marche
pas si par contre c'est assez récent on
va parler en semaine 1 jours ou semaines
si ces récents tu peux encore tenté tout
n'est pas perdu il ya plusieurs étapes
pour savoir si tu peux récupérer
l'histoire déjà il ya une question à se
poser c'est la tranche d'âge est ce que
ta nana elle rentre je dirais 15 ans et
25 ans première tranche d'âge ça c'est
la tranche d'âge des chaises en règle
générale et ensuite tu as à les 25-40
ans au dessus on ne se sépare pas ou
alors et je ne sais pas quoi dire un
sujet donc si elle entre 15 et 25 ans il
faut savoir que les fier cet âge là
elles ne veulent pas le mec parfait ne
veulent pas d'ailés cool
elles veulent pas un mec sympa ils
veulent pas mais qu romantique un mec
qui prennent soin d'elle même si elle se
disait j'aimerais avoir un mec super en
réalité elles veulent des super connard
en règle générale elles veulent plus
s'amuser découvrir même si elle s'est
toujours un peu fleur bleue romantique
cité saint pas citer le mec idéal à ce
moment là c'est là où tu vendes avait
moi j'étais plutôt un peu comme ça
plutôt le mec romantique le mec un peu
fleur bleue
à cet âge là les meufs tu les fais chier
par contre les nanas qui ont au dessus
de 25 ans et 35 40 ans elle veut le
contraire elles ont expérimenté les
connards elles ont soupé maintenant elle
va gueuler mais bien et c'est là où tu
peux laisser le côté fleur bleue
s'exprimer pas trop non plus elles
veulent des mecs un palais moliets pas
déçu folle il faut vraiment faire un
distinguo parce que c'est justement là
dessus que tu vas pouvoir analyser
pourquoi est-ce que ça n'a pas marché
et qu'est ce que tu vas pouvoir faire et
quelle leçon tu vas pouvoir tirer alors
après voilà il ya des choses qui sont
récupérables dans un groupe qui vient de
se séparer
il faut savoir pourquoi il ya des choses
qu'ils ne sont pas et puis y'a des fois
franchement il faut s'en foutrait de
passer à autre chose
la toute première chose à savoir pour
commencer c'est un ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire il ya quand tu viens de te faire
larguer en est le génial tu es dans le
mal et a tendance à faire n'importe quoi
tu l'appelles t'appelle saison
mutu l'art celte lui envoie des messages
crytek si tu ne veux plus jamais la
revoir c'est la meilleure chose à faire
surtout ne fait jamais ça jamais ça elle
vient de partir pas pour avoir un pot de
colle qui la fesci qui s'accrochent elle
tue la laisse partir
elle veut partir quelle part tu veux
prendre la porte dégage il ya aucun
problème avec courtoisie bien évidemment
parce que je te rappelle que but c'est
quand même de la récupérer donc si tu la
base ça marchera pas tu lui on va pas de
message tu ne l'as recèle pas tu ne
l'appelle pas tu fous la paix tu
n'existe plus elle veut plus de voir l
ait eu verra plus ça c'est la première
chose et surtout si tu veux le récupérer
ne panique pas et arrête de pleurnicher
sur toi même
ne restent pas tout seul surtout ne va
pas de bourrer la gueule parce qu'après
on est dans le bade et c'est là où on
fait des conneries et c'est là où
passent des coups de téléphone qu'on ne
devrait pas faire ne le fait pas rod
grosses erreurs à ne pas faire on
n'appelle pas ses amis ou sa famille
pour avoir leur avis parce que des fois
on dit oui mais c'est une erreur
elle m'a largué elle devrait pas je vais
essayer d'avoir plus d'infos où je vais
essayer de leur expliquer à eux qu elle
déconne et qu'il ne faut pas qu'elle
fonctionne comme ça si tu fais ça mon
gars tu es mort ils sont forcément son
côté ils vont lui dire bon forcément
l'appeler soit elle tapait les ailes
t'insulte tu l'aura mérité
soit c'est carrément mort fait griller
définitivement surtout tu n'appelles
aucun de ses proches et surtout ne
cherche pas la revoir à tout prix ça
c'est la base c'est ce qu'il ne faut
absolument pas faire
voici maintenant le point numéro 2 ce
qu'il faut faire la première chose tu
restes calme tu ne balise pas tu ne
flippe as tu reste zen
il faut fonctionner avec méthode dans
ces moments où on est relativement mal
on a plutôt tendance à laisser parler
ses émotions surtout pas avec ta tête
faut que ce soit à tête qui dicte tout
pas tes émotions si tu laisse parler ses
émotions est mort ça ne marchera pas une
meuf qui t'a quitté elle n'est
certainement pas d'un mot lucielle des
émotions de plein d'émotions qui déborde
de partout mais je t'aime et signer sa
elle s'en fout elle s'est barrée donc
n'ont pas d'émotions y est tu n'existes
pas le but si tu veux c'est de créer la
surprise
en règle générale on veut toujours ce
qu'on ne peut pas avoir donc si elle
voit qu'elle t'a que tes acquis que tu
es là que tu l'as suis comme un petit
toutou c'est mort si elle sent le
détachement et quand elle a des doutes
ou qu'elle était pas sur sa décision
ça va peut-être faire machine arrière
donc
tout tu te tais et tu disparais et tu
fais croire surtout que toi tu passe à
autre chose point numéro 3 il faut que
tu saches absolument pourquoi il t'a
quitté
est-ce qu'elle t'a quitté parce qu'elle
a not make auquel cas ces morts ne
serait ce que par fierté tu la
récupérera pas à l'état quitté pour un
autre mec
dégage ont trouvé une autre et je vais
continuer ma route
est-ce qu'elle t'a quitté parce que tu
as fait une erreur est-ce que tu l'a
trompée est ce que tu as fait une
connerie tu tapes et sa soeur d'étape et
sa mère qu'est ce qui s'est passé il
faut vraiment identifier le problème
si tu n'arrives pas à comprendre d'une
tu pourras pas la récupérer et de deux
ça risque de se reproduire plus tard il
faut vraiment identifie le souci
maintenant sans que dans une passerelle
autre chose elle n'est pas sûre d'aller
le doute pas encore ta carte à jouer et
c'est justement là dessus tu vas pouvoir
travailler quatrième point les points
que toi tu peux changer alors il ya tout
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on ne
change jamais à mon sens ne change pas
on peut essayer de progresser il ya des
voies de progression mais le changement
radical ça n'existe pas un mec qui va
dire à sanaa j'ai changé c'est mort elle
le verra parce que de toute façon au
bout d'un moment pour fonctionnement
d'avant sera en fonctionnement de demain
on ne change pas on peut par contre se
réorienter on peut progresser
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut que tu bosses
lui et moi on est la même personne mais
c'est tout assuré qu'entre les deux il
ya du chemin
d'ailleurs je crois qu'une bonne dizaine
d'années tu en penses quoi point numéro
il faut préparer ton action n'est pas un
bonjour quand on téléphone il ya bon bah
voilà en reprenant l'ensemble toute
façon ça ne marchera pas il faut être
beaucoup plus subtil en gros il faut que
tu arrives à lui faire croire que toi tu
as changé et qu'il ya des choses qui se
sont passées
il faut que tu la surprenne dis lui que
tu es au québec la rupture que ça ne
pose aucun problème que tu as compris tu
as compris pourquoi il était parti a
compris quelle était la raison
si elle est partie parce qu'elle avait
des raisons personnelles et qu'elle
avait besoin de voir autre chose
d'unique qui comprend parfaitement que
c'est naturel que tu acceptes et que tu
espère même que vous resterez alyssa
savall a su reprendre peut-être même la
vexer parce qu'elle va se dire en
réalité
pourquoi est-ce que le mec il passe
aussi vite à autre chose qu'un aréna
fout de moi
il n'aimait pas réellement c'est
toujours sans sa fierté ça peut la faire
revenir
sixièmement qui doit passer à l'action
il faut que tu la vois prétexte
n'importe quoi alors pas n'importe quoi
si tu fais le chien pathos ça ne
marchera pas par contre tu peux te
réveiller à votre écoute
j'aimerais bien qu'on se bat pour qu'on
clarifie les choses une dernière fois
qu'on reste amis et vous voyez ce qui va
être hyper important ce n'est pas tant
ce que tu vas lui dire ça va être la
communication non verbale c'est ce qui
va ressortir ses les messages que tu vas
faire passer il ya des petits détails
comme ça tu sais parce que si tu arrives
à comprendre pourquoi elle est partie et
sur quoi tu peux jouer trouvent les
clients ton discours et tu verras ça ça
marche communication non verbale ça va
être quoi ça va être les sourires il
faut que tu paraissent heureux épanoui
il faut vraiment que tu prennes sur toi
hésite pas quand tu parles à regarder un
petit peu ses lèvres c'est un côté un
peu sensuelle ça peut attirer puis ça
peut créer du désir si elle est vraiment
passé autre chose ça n'aura aucun impact
mais si par contre il ya encore une
petite ouverture
ça peut fonctionner quand tu la voir au
pire si tu as fait des conneries tu
t'excuses dit voilà écoute je me suis
rendu compte tu as raison tu as bien
fait de partir je le méritais j'ai fait
cette erreur
voilà ce qui s'est passé maintenant
j'espère qu'un jour peut-être on saura
se retrouver un mois j'ai pris la
décision de faire attention échanger et
grâce à toi j'ai vu des voix de
progression c'est un peu du blabla mais
faire son mea culpa c'est bien tu fais
ton mea culpa une fois une fois c'est
tout parce que la technique du chien qui
rampent elle n'a jamais fonctionné de
mes pages nous devra y tu l'as dit a
reconnu c'est bien il faut le faire
maintenant
basta ce qui est dit est dit il on ne
revient pas dessus et tu verras comment
elle réagit soit elles on trouve des
portes soit le retrouve pas si jamais on
trouve là tu rentres dedans
discrètement n'est pas un chien soit
fait étape à la dalle n'est pas un
crevard par contre si elle ne trouve
rien eh ben c'est pas grave vous partez
et puis tu verras après tu la laisses
revenir c'est elle qui leur reviendra
les c'est elle qui tend vers le premier
message laisse les jours passent et
septième point tu fais le bilan est ce
que ça a marché
est-ce que ça n'a pas marché est ce
qu'il ya une ouverture est ce qu'il ya
une ouverture que vous êtes vus est ce
qu'il ya eu un message après est-ce
qu'il ya eu des signes qui montrent
qu'elle est intéressée qu'elle est
réceptive si c'est le cas tu continues
tu rentres dans la brèche
toujours avec distance que c'est cette
distance cap et cette distance qui
marche si tu te relâches mais si tu fais
du pathos c'est mort-aux-rats rien si
maintenant ça ne marche absolument pas
qu'au bout de quelques jours tu n'as eu
aucun message tu lui en renvoie pas tu
laisses tomber et tu passe à autre chose
moi je peux t'assurer des ruptures
journée où je peux vous assurer que je
me suis fait beaucoup plus largué que je
n'ai larié mais que au final
aujourd'hui je suis très heureux et très
épanouie il faut que tu te dis
un truc c'est que on apprend toujours de
ses ruptures plus on est jeune quand on
a ces premières ruptures
c'est là où on en chie plus on a
l'impression que notre monde s'écroule
que ça ne repartira jamais que c'était
l'amour ta vie une station et c'était
pas la menthe avis souvent souffrent de
plus quand on est jeune parce qu'on
n'est pas mature émotionnellement et
quand ils pas mature c'est un autre en
prend plein la gueule tu as l'impression
d'être à poil et que tu as été
abandonnée moi j'ai eu plusieurs fois
sensation d'abandon à sensations qu'à
personnes avec qui tu partages et le
plus de moments partagés les moments les
plus intimes connaissait toute ta vie
qui était la pente se tenir
elle est abandonnée et au final tu te
rends compte qu'on n'abandonne pas c'est
juste que les gens bien là ils ont leur
vision leur chemin à faire et qui a des
fois leur chemin c'est plus dire quand
elle m'a quitté ben c'est pas grave j'en
ai chié et au final elle a dégagé et je
suis très heureux alors tu t'inquiètes
pas soit elle revient et tant mieux
et puis même si elle revient qu'elle
repart et ben c'est pas grave tu
apprends tu de blindes ne bascule pas du
côté obscur devient pas le connard ça
sert strictement rien reste toi même
soit honnête envers toi même sept plus
importants sites et honnête envers toi
même tu es honnête envers elle si elle
veut revenir à leurs biens si elle
revient pas tant pis next en tout cas
voilà tu as lu clés tu sais maintenant
un petit peu comment il faut faire tu
verras bien te prends pas la tronche
c'est à des questions un peu plus
personnel tu peux me lâcher un
commentaire si toutefois je peux essayer
de répondre je le ferai et pour conclure
je veux laisser mon ex de faire un gros
bisou